منسحبون ليس من ميدان المعارك وانما من
المسار الذي كان يؤمل في اي ينهي القتال
ما الذي دفع الجيش السوداني وقائده عبد
الفتاح البرهان الى تعليق المشاركه في
مفاوضات جده
[موسيقى]
انتجت تلك المفاوضات التي انطلقت قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع بواسطه امريكيه سعوديه جمله
من الهدد بين طرفي الصراع في السودان لم
تحترم
ذاك بالذات ما يقول الجيش السوداني انه
حرك قراره
فهو بخروجه عن مسار التفاوض انما يحتج على
هجمات يقول ان قوات الدعم السريع تشنها
على مواقعه في العاصمه والولايات
مقربون من البرهان وبقيه قيادات الجيش
تحدث ايضا عن انزعاجهم من غياب ضغط كاف
على قوه حميتي لحملها على الخروج من
الاحياء السكنيه والمشافي
الالتزام اذا هو المشكله لكل طرف هنا
روايته لكن المتقاتلين ملزمون كما يفترض
باعلان جده الذي من مبادئه عدم السعي
لتحقيق مكاسب على الارض خلال وقف اطلاق
النار
لا يسع احدا نفي استمرار القتال وان
تراجعت حدته في ظل اتفاق الهدنه الذي
استمر اسبوعا قبل ان يمدد العمل به لخمسه
ايام
لم تروا من هدنه في الوقت الراهن تسويه
سياسيه دائمه للصراع بل حركتها دواعي
انسانيه جعلت اولويتها حمايه المدنيين
وتامين ايصال المساعدات اليهم
هذا جهد يخشى ان يواجه مزيدا من التعقيد
مع خروج احد طرفي النزاع من دائره التفاوض
فماذا عن الطرف الاخر لن تشهد هنا خروجا
الى العلن على طريقه البرهان لايضاح
الموقف فليس القائد الاول لقوات الدعم
السريع ما يفعلها وانما شقيقه القائد
الثاني في تلك القوات الظاهر هنا مع رجاله
عبد الرحيم دقلو دعا قوات الجيش للخروج
على البرهان والتنسيق مع الدعم السريع
كقوه واحده وقال ان الدعم لن تقف مع عناصر
النظام السابق الذين يدين البرهان بالولاء
لهم حسب تعبيره
ما ممكن لكن ماذا عن حميدتي المتواري منذ
فتره عن الانظار يقول شقيقه انه بخير وانه
يقاتل في الصفوف الاماميه مع قواته